dude picked third in the 95 draft joe  smith  oh goodness  alabama get away the shove on the board  shackleford  okoro rejected that one this time he  makes a play out of the corner  with a violent cut to the rim off the  penetration of mccormick  mitchell looking for the flush now  auburn with numbers little euro left  hand okoro  and try and force auburn to  shoot threes contested threes agoro  feeds it into the post  late in the shot clock and austin wiley  scores the first points on senior night  kermit davis was also ejected in that  game for picking up a couple of  technicals and all of his time  coaching only three a yoke job  by williams okoro on a three  he got it that's huge man his  three-point shot is starting to come  along